JESSICA DENE
EARLEY-CHA: Hi there.
Building an Action is exciting.
But building an Action
without testing it,
and simply hoping it's going
to work, isn't best practices.
I would never create
a website and only
render the page at the end.
My CSS would be
all kinds of wonky.
Wouldn't it be great that
you could code a little,
and then test your
Action to make sure it's
working before you deploy it?
Ta-da-- the Actions Simulator.
I made an Action that's
all about telling jokes
about fruit.
While I was building
it, I tested it out
on the Action Simulator.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
What did the strawberries say
when they were given a gift?
Thank you berry much.
JESSICA DENE
EARLEY-CHA: [LAUGHS]
[FAIL SOUND]
You could see the requests,
the response objects,
as well as errors and the audio.
You can even test out your
Actions on different surfaces,
like on your phone, audio-only
devices like Google Home,
and smart displays.
You can even test out
in different languages.
SPEAKER 2: OK.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
JESSICA DENE
EARLEY-CHA: [LAUGHS]
[FAIL SOUND]
There are so many tools
in Actions Simulator
that help you while you're
developing your Action.
Check out the Docs
for more information.
Let us know what you build on
Twitter by using the hashtag
#AoGDevs.
I'm Jessica Dene Earley-Cha.
Thanks for watching, and I look
forward to see what you build.